n'en déplaise à certains on rencontre
parfois l'amour irréversible victor et
moi c'est toute une histoire
je savais déjà que c'était autour de lui
que toute ma vie s'articulerait comment
tu t'appelles ça va j'étais quand même
moustique est attiré par une ampoule sur
le point que je sais pas si c'est
l'alcool ou si elle est devenue moche
pendant je dormais mais on réalise
[ __ ] c'était plus la même vous avez à
noter tout est oui
le problème c'est qu'elle va me castrés
vous savez très bien j'ai pu beaucoup de
coups et peut-être ça le problème c'est
aussi d'avoir une forme s'il vous plaît
bon c'est vrai qu'elle adore faire
l'amour avec ma fille je sais pas
pourquoi ils m'ont craché au visage
comme ça tu appelles ça une copine donne
moi j'appelle ça une [ __ ] au au clown
sera ensuite une souris noire qui
picolent en plus - vannes rennes
j'ai même plus besoin de boire c'est à
votre cassette film victor adelman
bonsoir bonsoir victorin des albums
oui c'est qu'ils tuent
quand j'ai commencé la tête d'un acteur
qui écrivait des livres maintenant j'ai
vraiment la tête d'un type qui fait
légale
sourit mois
tu es la femme la plus dingue que j'ai
jamais français alors pourquoi tu veux
ressembler anne aymone giscard d j'ai
choisi la qui ne peuvent pas être
impressionné par ce que je fais parce
que j'écris parce que je pense pas trop
vite mon amour là
marie 12 ans
pour régis pleure parce que c'est bien
j'étais une femme c'est exactement comme
ça que je dirais pour aller retrouver
quelqu'un
patty duke un homme c'est exactement
comme ça que j'agirais pour que ma femme
ce tir
[Musique]
j'aime bien tout ce qu'elle dit le
regard qu'elle cause surtout les gens
les films
des temps
j'ai tout ce dont je rêvais